[Aplausos]
diabetes de cuántas personas han oído
que el muerto de diabetes o aún peor
cuántos familiares suyos han muerto de
diabetes en mi caso al muerto bastantes
familiares y se me hace muy triste tan
solo poderme quedar con sus recuerdos
así que imagínense unas lentes que
monitorean la diabetes imagínense poder
entrar a un salón de clases oa una
oficina con unos lentes que parecen ser
totalmente comunes pero en realidad te
están monitoreando el azúcar pero sí que
están pensando existen las bombas de
insulina pero son muy diferentes ya que
en esto te tienes que pinchar el dedo
para saber qué tan alta o tan baja
tienes el azúcar así es como tú te la
pinches tú decides cuándo crees que ya
la tienes o muy alta o muy baja pero tal
vez tú crees que es tan normal y ya se
te subió mucho hoy es de trabajo aparte
estos lentes estarían monitoreando el
azúcar para saber si lo tienes muy alta
o muy baja
si tienes seguir monitoreando pero como
te la monitorean bueno obtendrá una
lanita en el lente de la parte del ente
cerca de la oreja para que se los
escuche es la arb y está aparte para
algunas personas puede ser que sea
penoso tener que entrar con una bomba de
insulina y tenerse que pinchar el dedo
pero cómo fue que decidimos este tema
bueno es que la diabetes es un problema
muy grande en méxico y es momento de
decir basta así que los invitamos a que
como nosotros les los compartimos
nuestra idea ustedes comparta la suya
para cambiar nuestro futuro gracias
[Aplausos]